hallo ihr lieben ich hoffe ihr seid gut
regeneriert und erholt aus der gestrigen
einheit heute wieder mit dabei gestern
war militärisch fitness hohe körperliche
belastung
heute machen wir weiter mit einem kraft-
ausdauer- programm für die beine
beziehungsweise wer mal in rumpf immer
wieder mit dazu nehmen der gerry ist
dabei jeder peter bin mit dabei und wir
haben heute wieder einen spezialgast
unter uns eine bahn radsportlerin
zweiter bei den european games aber am
besten ist sie stellt sich ganz gut
selbst vor und dann kam aschersleben
bitteschön
ja hallo ich bin die varena eberhard
übrigen 26 jahre alt und harris sport
leistungssportlerin in der südstadt und
ja richtig gewinn bahn radsportlerin und
habe in den letzten jahren schon einige
schöne erfolge feiern können wie
silbermedaille bei den european games
oder eine weltcup metalle aus rauchern
gibt es da alles was dein tagesablauf
irgendwie da sportlich mit mit
mitgestaltet oder ist das hauptsächlich
am rad sehr viel training findet
wirklich am rad statt und aktuell bin in
der off-season da mache ja sehr viel
alternativ training wie laufen oder bin
relativ länder kraftkammer okay woraus
vorbereitung dass der körper
leistungsfähig in die nächste saison
gehen kann war noch immer sie los geht
oder gehen muss flexibel sein wenn du
warst du bei uns bist dann spart man mit
unseren trainingsprogramm für heute wir
beginnen wieder mit aufwärmen ein
laufend bewegen mobilisieren und dann
schauen was die verena und so als für
spezial übungen am mittwoch hat bei
gerade im radsport ist es so dass man
nach dem es so viel in dieser gebückten
geknickten position quasi sitzt dass man
das sehr viel kollektiv arbeiten muss
das heißt drücken wieder aufrichten
becken spannung beziehungsweise becken
strecken wieder herstellen muss und wie
gesagt das schauen wir uns an was wir
uns da alles mitgebracht hat okay dann
würde vorschlagen legen wir los ein
laufen laufen am stand ganz locker
herz-kreislauf-system in schwung bringen
körper aktivieren zu sagen jetzt geht
was los jetzt passiert was und
ihrerseits mit der bayern es ist super
cool
wenn man hört bahnradsport denkt man
natürlich momentan klarerweise kannst du
sicher stadion also - sogar ein wenig
härter du kommst du uns wo trainierst du
jetzt oder in zukunft hier aktuell noch
glücklicherweise musiker demnächst muss
man dann auf bahnen ja in der nähe
ausweichen das wird wahrscheinlich unter
anderem in tschechien sein
sie warnen die draußen sind ohne dach
das ist jetzt im winter auch keine
alternative möglichkeit finden ja das
war ein violetter hat den weg das ist
ganz klar an die leistungssportler
seiner dass er bereit natürlich auch
strapazen auf sich zu nehmen
aber die beine ausland kann fangen wir
an arme kreisen ganz locker vorwärts
kreisen
ich habe eigens leighton gehört dass es
vielleicht doch in österreich in zukunft
ein stadion wieder geben so dass
gerüchte bestätigen ja für mich sind
auch informationen also es gibt gerüchte
dass vielleicht in der nähe versank
wollten eine paarung gehört wird das war
natürlich dann cool wenn mal wieder ein
österreicher sei es wichtig eine
handvoll seine zurück
und laut mal wieder kurz am stand das
heißt du bist im bahnradsport
österreichs nummer eins kann man sagen
ja kann man sagen super
das heißt du trainierst wie viele
stunden am rad
aber du bist also 15 stunden darauf
schließen da kann man sicher wieder
scheibe abschneiden
also viele machen in der offseason der
tochter gar nichts oder weit bedeutet
weniger mobilisieren große bereiche im
körper was er für übung her der übung
dem auch mal gern der mann für da haben
wir mobilität entlang der wirbelsäule
drinnen oberschenkel kommt ein bisschen
unter spannung und ich habe gleichzeitig
dynamische komponente drin
stolzer brust gerne aktiv gespannt
muskulär abgesichert ihr kennt das
bereits
er müsste entsprechend aktiv sein in der
rotation von links nach rechts kurz aus
lockern was man auch welchen kreisen
dankeschön wir fangen wieder an eine
richtung zu kreisen der kenda variieren
große kreise machen kleinere kreise
machen richtung wächst und immer wieder
als selbständig 23 mal hin und her
wechseln
wir haben sich speziell auf bevor er
aufs rad steigt oder ist an das
aufwärmen am rad
jetzt ist einfach natürlich vorher
speziell auf aber aber nicht mit
radfahren oder ausland bewegen uns
wieder kurz am stand aber gerade der
bereich nacken beziehungsweise rücken
glaube dann leidet man als radsportler
stark unter verspannungen und schmerzen
oder ja das sind teilweise die muskeln
sehr verkürzt wenn wir doch in einer
sehr vor geprägten sitzung in einer
sachfrage projekten position genau weil
je weiter unten desto weniger
windwiderstand quasi nach standort auf
der bahn denke mal ist es sicher
ganz wichtiger punkt da hatte ich
geschwindigkeiten sein ist er wichtiger
ist es eigentlich so mehr freut dass ins
gewicht genau so ist es anfassen
natürlich knie heben dass wir immer
wieder zwischen rehna einbauen
das ist kennt ihr das macht mal okay
dann locker mal kurz aus nachdem erste
das thema angesprochen haben der
halswirbelsäule mobile media bewegen wir
dir bisserl dass man da entsprechend da
vielleicht einer kleinen verspannung hat
bisschen entgegen wirken können
das war mein blick wendung linke rechte
seite hin und her da kann man ruhig
schauen dass der oberkörper wirklich
komplett ruhig komplett stabil ist und
nur die halswirbelsäule sie bewegt ja
erkennt dass es so ruhig bleiben genau
und hin und her bewegen und auf und ab
und dann kippt mein kopf von der linken
auf die rechte seite
und locker mal wieder aus bewegen wir
uns wieder ganz kurz an stand laufen
boxer lauf machen was auch immer gerade
bewegung so dazu passt ja du hast
angefangen mit bock salat danach wird er
auch weiter genau sagen wie viele
kilometer fast du im jahr kameras song
[Musik]
das heißt es ist auch wenn das jetzt
sagen das bedeutet weniger wieder
straßenradsport nur dass man da ein
vergleich vom tiefen aber es trotzdem
17.000 kilometer ist jetzt kreisform
muss man sich jetzt vorstellen natürlich
dann auch besondere herausforderung weil
wir uns einer die disziplinen relativ
kurzen so 20 kilometer manchmal die
ganze energie rein genau dafür dass
tagen intensiver eigentlich gerne
kilometer fast drei jahren im radio rsr
der boxer genau und autofahrer und
weniger der radfahrer aber wie gesagt ja
ausschütteln
wir haben einmal ein großteil
mobilisiert wir gehen aber weiter was
ist deine lieblings mobil ist hier übung
führen rücken was machst du gerne haben
wo sie gern noch ist einfach die hüfte
zu öffnen und zwar indem man sich so
vorbeugt und einen fuß zur seite streckt
sozusagen nach vorn zurück lebt okay und
das ist ja abgewandelte version nichts
von der übung der mann das letzte mal
gemacht haben zum becken mobilisieren
das heißt ich darf dir einmal ganz kurz
bieten dass du uns die zweite variante
mittel auf beiden knien einer zeigt das
heißt erst einmal runter auf beide klubs
auseinander
vielleicht ist wohl jetzt kennt die
übung und jeeps das becken nach hinten
und wieder nach vor genau und eine
variante davon ist es mit dem
gestreckten bein das zu machen darfst
rück wieder in deine position
hineingehen wichtig dabei geht in eure
geht es in eine leichte lose das heißt
das becken ist entsprechend nach hinten
oben gerichtet und nicht in einen
rundrücken hinein und das ist das wo man
dann wirklich schön in die hüfte
hineinkommt 20 mal 25 mal so was jetzt
da gut sie kurz es geht
wechseln wir mal die seite
und das ist ein punkt das habe ich
vorher angesprochen der radsportler
arbeitsjahr für korrektiv das heißt
ausbessern und ausgleichend zu dem was
sein sport einfach mitbringt und wenn
man sich vorstellt man sitzt in einer
gebuchten position stundenlangen rat
dann ist es natürlich für die
beweglichkeit in der hüfte jetzt nicht
optimal
ja und das ist eine übung wie man da
wieder dagegen arbeiten kann dass man
diese beweglichkeit wieder herstellen
kann so dass man seinen alltag ganz
normal schmerzfrei und in einer
aufrechten gesunden position auch dann
verbringen kann
ich habe manchmal nur fünf
wiederholungen und stehen wir wieder
auflockern mal aus schob eine
ausschüttung weil das ist ein wichtiger
punkt wenn ich so einer spannungs
position drinnen war muss ich natürlich
dann schauen dass sie die spannung aber
wieder raus krieg oder weil es ist ja
unangenehm dann wenn man länger in der
position war und dann lockert man das
einfach kurz aus gary was ist deine
lieblings übung zu mobilisieren der
hüfte genau also gekämpft die übung
bereits zehenspitzen nach innen spitz
nach außen schauen dass die knie
gestreckt bleiben das heißt möglich
möglichst ein stabiles quasi bein zu
haben
und wenn ihr dann aus und einträgt komme
ich natürlich schön in die hüfte auch
hinein
und wir haben vorher bereits auch
angesprochen dass korrektive arbeiten
und da ist natürlich äußerst
oberschenkelrückseite gesäß und den
rücken betrifft natürlich ein thema das
wir uns einerseits mit
kräftigungsübungen und andererseits an
mit mobilisation und mit kurzen an denen
beziehungsweise den übungen an anschauen
wie das sie wirklich einige tausend
kilometer im jahr am ratssitz wieder
sieht es wieder gut hingekriegt ohne wie
gesagt dass sie zu viel schmerzen dann
habe das wäre natürlich kontraproduktiv
sport zu betreiben und dann in der
freizeit schmerzen zu haben erst jetzt
umgekehrt sein okay stämme auf normalmaß
die arena hat sich ja übung für uns weil
man es gut angesprochen haben
oberschenkel beweglichkeit
beziehungsweise gesäßmuskulatur und
alles was dazu erklärt dafür die bieten
zeigt eine übung vor ich gehe ich war
gern den armen nach vorne zurück und
somit den vergleich der
oberschenkelrückseite mit somit hätte
man schon wieder geschafft dass man
zumindest einen teilbereich des
liegestütz in unserem werk drinnen haben
aber wie ich erinnerte was nach vor
ihnen die liegestütz ausgestellt und
dann wieder zurück zehn mal mit dabei
wäre doof ist mit dabei geht schon los
und auch wenn da im ersten satz das knie
komplett gestreckt habt oder leichten
buch drinnen habe es nicht so tragisch
so lange hat den zug in der
oberschenkelrückseite vielleicht im
wasser oder in im gesäß endspurts
masaccio am richtigen weg
im optimalfall natürlich dann das knie
irgendwann gestreckt
und wenn er natürlich dass anno
probieren wo jetzt lasst die fia so
lange wie es geht am boden das dann so
kleinigkeiten wenn man sie auf die
konzentriert da kann man dann nur mehr
aus der übung rausholen gerne an meiner
nur denen und mobilisieren die ehre ist
nicht drin oder muss man immer ein
bisserl oft anders zu verbringen
das heißt da war die kombination
natürlich dann mit dem liegestütz eine
mögliche gesetz aber für die
beweglichkeit aus der
oberschenkelrückseite heraus netzer
tragisch und man stelle sich jetzt vor
die verena hat eine ähnliche mehr
wiederkehren das wäre beim bau von der
nicht unbedingt förderlich
einerseits das gewicht was man natürlich
mit herumführt in dem fall wäre störend
und wie gesagt deswegen ist er als
fahrer und der box oder boxen 62 und
kurz weil man vom aktivieren müssen uns
aber voll flott bewegen
aber das machen wir jetzt gemeinsam und
starten in fünf sekunden 3 2 1 los
schnell hin und wieder zurück
[Applaus]
drei männer und ein mal noch entweder
auslagern
ok ich glaube wir haben jetzt ganz gut
den körper vorbereitet auf die übungen
auf die belastung die jetzt folgt wir
fangen mit der ersten raum für woran
templates garrett sagst du mal vor und
dann stets unterarme parallel kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule stolze post
knöchel knie hüfte schulter in einer
ebene
das ist die ausgangsstellung die nehmen
das ist quasi die mindestanforderung ist
jetzt einmal 30 sekunden diese position
zu halten
und dann gibt es natürlich hier auch die
dynamische komponente dass man im
sekunden rhythmus dass bei einem wechsel
hebt so zehn zentimeter ungefähr dass
beim hochheben genau ihr sechstes und
damit schließen wir wieder den kreis ein
bissel vom rumpf üben von der kraft
quasi die radsportler braucht hin zur
soldaten fitness gerade im
sportmotorischen test beim soldaten ist
es so dass man diese übung im programm
mit drinnen haben und zu mindestens 90
sekunden wäre gut wenn der soldat das
ganze machen könnte ich korrigiere ganz
kurz becken hat diese bisschen tiefer
bitte genau und das bein musst gar nicht
so hoch heben und die unterarme parallel
bitte und jetzt wird schon wieder
richtig schwierig
und wie gesagt 90 sekunden muss das eine
art aber schaffe wäre was hast du in
deiner besseren zeiten schafft 430 war
beim letzten test also das muss man
schon mal kann man gerne mal
ausprobieren das ist schon richtig
richtig anstrengend okay die 30 sekunden
haben wir durch gary go als die minute
fertig oder spas sowie bisschen
überrascht okay wer rennen darf sie
bitten das du kurzem aufstehst und aus
hass wir machen nur gemeinsam die
kniebeuge schauen wieder auf welche
punkte muss man achten
ok wack doch mal die kniebeuge vor ja
weil wir haben die möglichkeit einer
halb kniebeuge oder viertel kniebeuge
oder dann auch einer tief gebäude in dem
fall ist es wahrscheinlich von der
beweglichkeit der vom radfahrer so dass
dort vermutet dann war das ziemlich
eingeschränkt ist ja ich bin ein bisserl
verkürzen
es geht also die folge ist genauso
tränen minute ist durch kniebeuge halb
kniebeuge beziehungsweise tief kniebeuge
kurz aus locker nahmen durch probieren
aber die bewegung machen und in 10
sekunden starten mit 30 sekunden
kniebeugen und da kriegt man schon
richtiger kraft darin die oberschenkel
sein und das ist sicher etwas was man im
antritt auch beim bahnradsport immer
brauchen kann
ok bereit los gehts 30 sekunden
kniebeuge achtet auf eure beinachse das
heißt hüfte knie und zehenspitzen
ungefähr eine andere ebene
das knie nicht nach ihnen schlagen
lassen oder nach außen strahlen lassen
hat ist eigentlich gegen der relevanz
man sieht das immer wieder bei
radfahrern die ganz eng die beine am
oberrohr vom rat führen ja es klingt
natürlich wieder was für die übernahme
gehen ja dass die beine
die achsen eigentlich am rahmen an nicht
anlehnen wieder kontraproduktiv okay
aber schon auch aus einer stabilen
position heraus aus locker 30 sekunden
sind vorbei das heißt da schaut man
natürlich dass man entsprechend aber in
summe relativ schmal ist weil man den
luftwiderstand irgendwo minimieren
möchte aber jetzt jedes mal mit dem knie
am oberrhein zu haben wir natürlich
jetzt nicht optimal was machen als
nächstes nächste übung machen wir übung
für die rückenmuskulatur für die
rückenstrecke bzw
die beine dann vielleicht in einer
variante mit dazu dann haben wir eine
und hintereinander mit dabei während
bitte zeigen aber vor der übung
wir gehen in bauchlage barklage hände
beine weg wir bewegen abwechselnd arme
und beine nicht drehen gleich hände und
oder arme und beine nach oben dankeschön
gerne zweite variante
es gibt mehr beraten
und wir arbeiten mit den oberkörper und
da ist die möglichkeit dass man ein
bisschen nach links und nach rechts
wandert mit den oberkörper genau sucht
sich eine aus die für euch gut passt 30
sekunden geht's los und ich denke gerade
die muskulatur aus dem rücken strecke
heraus ist sicherlich eine die beim
radfahrer ganz wichtig ist um die
haltung die position auch am rad richtig
halten zu können
ja das ist richtig und es kommt
natürlich auch viel kraft dann aus den
unternehmen rücken muss man sagen
und je besser man in rumpf trainiert es
desto besser bringt man eigentlich die
kraft dann auch auf die pedale würde
sein okay dort 30 sekunden haben ja wer
jetzt machst du weiter der gehry hat die
übung abgebrochen jetzt bist du dabei
eine minute zu arbeiten und wir zeigen
euch die nächste aus dem unterarm stütze
raus das rotieren das aufdrehen des
oberkörpers das heißt wir eine
dynamische komponente im plenk drinnen
im unterarm stets gern mal vor bitte bei
einhand hochheben nachschauen unter dem
körper durch drehen und absetzen die
minute ist durch kurz aus locker andere
seite durchgreifen so weit wie es geht
hinein drehen und wieder handwechsel
system erkannt das macht mal 30 sekunden
über das ganze und in 10 sekunden legen
wir los das heißt probiert zusammen aus
von der bewegung her
schade dass das hinkriegt und wie gesagt
wenn die rotation nicht ganz möglich ist
das jetzt einfach stabiler im stück
bleibt 21 uhr los geht's 30 sekunden
arbeiten und da doch wichtig becken ist
gestreckt dass dahinter nicht angespannt
die schale sie mit dem hintern nicht zu
hoch kommt der kopf ist in verlängerung
der wirbelsäule und stress beim drehen
habe überhaupt kann ja das heißt so
langsam und kontrolliert drehen das
basteln gut durchgreifen hochdrehen
nachschauen so hoch wie man draufkommt
kameruner aufdrehen 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit hammer erledigt kurz
ausschlafen verena der kurzausflug kann
ja und dann wechselt mal wieder in eine
rücken übung auch da wieder kombiniert
mit beine beziehungsweise
gesäßmuskulatur was wollt ihr da gerade
übungen die brücke ihr kennt das wir
kennen es wird sagen sind sicher zur
übernahme vor aufpassen müssen sie
achten stabile position aus dem rücken
heraus beinachse bleibt auch in der
opposition kontrolliert und stabil
fersen sind am boden becken kommt hoch
bei 1 strecken wie as cannes werden
nicht bleibt mit beiden beinen am boden
und dann heben und senken des beckens
und ok zurück ganz rausheben ganz raus
schieben hintern zusammen zwicken und
wirklich nach oben drücken
beide varianten möglich jedes mal das
bein wechseln oder 30 30
die variante 30 30 und 45 sekunden geht
es schon wieder los
21 rechtes bein strecken becken heben
und senken kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule
das heißt genau in das becken hoch geht
der blick nach oben und so ins becken
wieder runtergeht der kopf bewegt sie
einfach mit dem oberkörper mit ihr setzt
hochkommen körper geht zurück kopf geht
zurück und dann runter gehen geht
einfach wieder mit drei sekunden
er ist oben bist wirklich hinter den
sonstigen genau und ganz rauf drücken
das ist ganz wichtig bei der übung 2 1
und kurz aus lockern und wir schauen
dass man die rückenstrecke und in die
gesäßmuskulatur beinmuskulatur in die
gesamte muskel klebte hinten noch
reinarbeiten dass wir auch mal die
zweite seite und legen in fünf sekunden
gleich wieder los zeit läuft 30 sekunden
zweite seite das heißt winkels
bahnstrecken beiden heben und senken
und wer merkt dass geht es nicht ganz so
aus von der belastung her einfach beide
beine am boden beide fersen am boden und
das becken rauf und runter dann kommt
sie in die muskulatur
auch sehr gut hinein 5 sekunden und
übung abgeschlossen anstrengend man
sitzt da muss gearbeitet das ist ein
wichtiges zeichen
er kann sich entwickeln meiner gefordert
wird wenn er nicht gefordert wird
entwickelt ja nix jetzt haben den rücken
gehabt jetzt müssen wir natürlich den
bauch dazu machen dass das passt das
heißt aus der entsprechenden raum
spannung heraus eben auch für die
bauchmuskulatur vater xaver gesagt
manchmal erinnert sagen wir den
zuschauern vor
wie das ganze aus speziellen rückenlage
gerne erkennt die hände und das gesäß
nehmen streckt die beine aus und bewegt
auf und ab erkennt sie ziehen lang
machen wir kennst die zehn an flexen ist
alles in ordnung
es ist auch eine variante dass sie mit
den oberkörper hoch bleibt und
entsprechend arbeitet oder auch beide
beine hebt uns längst in der
unterschiedlichen ausführung mit la
grace beziehungsweise flattr kicks 30
sekunden wo immer arbeiten sehen und
zeit läuft ab jetzt wäre da schon in 20
länder position ja dann wird es zeit
wurde oder schwache minuten arbeitszeit
aber ich bin sicher du schaffst du
meinst es aus knie schon gestreckt
lassen
zumindestens kämpfen darum die position
aber auch schon wirklich anstrengend
wird zehn sekunden
noch fünf und bauchmuskeln kurz
entlasten kurz schütteln vielleicht
einmal aufstehen aber ausschüttung und
war ganz wichtige übung für die
beinmuskulatur und es ist sehr komplexe
übung sind die schritt sprünge ja das
schauen wir uns jetzt als abschließende
übung schauen wir uns jetzt den schritt
sprung an
wichtig für euch ist kontrollierte
rehbein achse das heißt wenn ihr landet
darf das knie nicht nach ihnen schlagen
sondern bleibt stabil
geht es runter macht den wechsel und
schaut dass wieder ein stabiles knie hat
das ist es ganz ganz ganz wichtige bei
der übung verena bereit wäre bereit
dann 30 sekunden schritt sprung im
wechsel kontrolliert die beinachse und
arbeit sei aber die position der arme
gestaltet sie ein bisschen danach meinen
oberkörper noch mit belasten möchte dann
nicht wenn ich die hände nach oben
strecken oder zur schläfe gibt habe
natürlich wesentlich mehr stabilisation
zuarbeit aus dem oberkörper heraus zu
leisten waren die hände in der hüfte
sind ist deshalb viel weniger aber die
beine dann trotzdem massiv belastet
sehen sie konnten fünf herauslocken
ausschütteln und nachdem die übung so
hohe wichtigkeit hat man auch mal 30
sekunden pause und da machen sich gar
zweites mal sich das geht es war eine 20
kilometer oder 15 kilometer auf der bahn
richtig anpacken kann dann gehen zweimal
schritt sprünge und ich bin sicher hier
zu hause machte mit und wenn es nicht
ganz so intensiv vom tempo her geht
einfach langsamer machen und es ist
genauso gut sehen sie konnten zweiter
durchgang schritt springer 5
ausgangs position 32 jetzt auf eure
position ich wiederhole
bei maxxim muss passen oberkörper ist
aufrecht rumpfmuskulatur ist unter
spannung das heißt die wirbelsäule ist
in ihrer natürlichen position muskulär
abgesichert und schön dynamisch hin und
her wechseln zehn sekunden leute und
sagen die zweiten 30 erledigt noch fünf
vier drei zwei eins sein ausschütteln
auslagern
gott sei das war ganz ein kleiner
einblick in ein graf training rumpf
training wie es die verena gerne und
auch regelmäßig in der übergangsperiode
beziehungsweise auch vorbereitungs
periode macht warum machen wir das warum
ist es sehr wichtiger punkt wir haben
schon gesagt für ein radfahrer natürlich
korrektiv das ganze und für uns für alle
anderen ist das krafttraining natürlich
auch eine variante ohne entsprechend
einerseits beweglich zu halten und
andererseits mein muskelkater soweit
aufzubauen dass sie in
alltagssituationen das gut überstehen
kann das heißt die kann ohne probleme
was hochheben das sind mal den rücken
nicht verletzt oder sonst irgendwas und
das sieht man ja immer wieder im fokus
haben sich körperlich fit zu halten um
auch gesund und fit die ganzen dinge
machen zu können
die also im alltag begegnen okay ganz
lockeres mama mama darüber hinaus cool
down heißt es richtig zum schluss was
haben wir da für übungen was macht dir
gerne was machst du gerne nach der
gaskammer haben ausschütteln
ausschütteln aus lockern genauso wenn
man vielleicht die lendenwirbelsäule
kurz ein bisschen mobilisieren dass man
da ein bisschen beweglichkeit
reinkriegen den heiss kurz mobilisieren
den kopf bewegen den kopf drehen
oberkörper verdrehen dass solche übungen
die hammer die letzten wochen mit euch
gemeinsam aber immer gemacht am besten
ist er sucht solchen cool da die übung
aus die ich selbst einfach am meisten
sagt ja das kann man in wahrheit nicht
viel falsch machen
man muss nur den druck rausnehmen die
belastung rausnehmen und dann
entsprechend sich aus denen aus bewegen
und dann ist alles gut
eine übermacht man nur gemeinsam setzt
sich bitte auf die matte fersen am boden
angewinkelte beine leicht geöffnete
position und lass doch mal eine links
und rechts zum boden herunter name genau
da kommt in die hüfte noch ein bisschen
rein bekommen den unteren rücken nahm
ein bisserl hinein
manchmal auch bei wiederholungen ein
bisserl noch hin und her okay dann
ausnahme aufstehen verena ich sage danke
dass du für uns fast abwechslung im
trainingsalltag jahre vertritt natürlich
jetzt wird zweiter schön was ist auch
vorsicht besonders zu achten wenn jetzt
wieder rausfahren geht wenn man wieder
raus geht muss man hast du den leuten zu
hause mit geben ich hoffe dass die leute
eigentlich die aktivität beibehalten
diese jetzt das vielleicht dem loggt man
sich angewöhnt haben dass sie weiterhin
aktiv bleiben die wichtigkeit und die
priorität einfach in der bewegung im
sport wenn der alltag wieder sich
normalisiert genau nicht vergisst darauf
dass weitermacht und wenn man jetzt bei
den schönen wir haben einen temperaturen
dann wieder ralf angeht vorsichtig sein
dass ramona funktioniert die bremse
funktioniert sie nicht und dann
entsprechend vorsichtig die ersten
ausfahrten machen genau jährige sogar
danke fürs mit danke dass ihr mit dabei
war
ja wir haben mit euch ein beim training
und rumpf training in der kombination
gemacht leistungssportlerin die varena
die bahn radsportlerin hat uns damit
begleitet und wir freuen uns auf die
nächste trainingseinheit und den machen
wir keine ungewohnte zeit gewohnt ort
wir sehen uns morgen